hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar current covid 19 testing
landscape
the role of antigen testing in a
molecular world
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by via soren
to learn more visit them at diaspora.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as
many questions as you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
also this presentation is educational
and offers continuing education
credits please follow the process to
obtain those credits
by clicking on the continuing education
credits
window i'd now like to welcome our
speaker dr nam
tran professor of pathology and
laboratory medicine at uc
davis health dr chan welcome you may now
begin
your presentation sir
great hello everyone definitely a big
thanks to lab roots
and so on for allowing me to present
today
and as noted today we're going to talk
about the current covid19 testing
landscape and really the role of antigen
testing
in a molecular world i'm nam tran so my
background is i'm a clinical chemist
board certified clinical chemist
but i also have extensive background in
molecular infectious disease testing and
played a role
in deployment of several molecular tests
for coven 19 during this pandemic at our
institution
i also serve on the california coven 19
testing task force as well
some quick disclosures i am a consultant
for roche diagnostics and roche
molecular systems
and our institution specifically the
molecular lab is a roche diagnostics
molecular center of excellence
and that's a picture of our institution
up there in northern california for
those that don't know where uc davis is
located we're specifically located
in the city of sacramento and that's our
health system whereas the college itself
is located in the city of davis hence
the name
so some quick learning objectives our
goal here is to really talk about the
practices of anagen testing you see big
red words down there that the slide is
current as of march 1st
and this indicates how fast the science
is moving right now and as we've
done since march 2020 data comes out
new each morning each day as we look
through the internet and of course
guidelines may change
in the same manner so we're going to
talk about cdc
guidelines we're going to talk about
best practices we're going to talk about
how point of care testing versus high
throughput cov2 antigen testing
can compare against molecular approaches
and then discuss considerations
for using sars cov2 energy testing in
asymptomatic versus symptomatic
populations
in resource limited settings and these
are kind of the key areas that we'll
focus on today
so keeping up with this epidemiological
data is
quite challenging because the number
gets bigger and bigger each morning i
wake up
but for the most part and this is dated
from january you can see that
we have over 100 million cases in the
world and as you know covet 19
stem from asia as we understand it and
of course spread across
the world and of course the united
states leads in terms of a number of
cases which highlights
considerations of what type of testing
practices we should follow
as numbers continue to rise across our
um
states and various other regions in
north america and of course here's a
picture
of of statistics as of january 27th uh
how the united states fared during
the covet 19 pandemic and you can see
that some states fared better than
others
some states if you look back in time had
more cases
per their population than others but now
are doing better and all these vary
because of population density
various practices of social distancing
and masking
as well as other measures being put into
place including testing
capacity and so on but for the most part
you can see that we have over 25 million
total cases the number continues to grow
and the number of deaths do uh or have
reached a level where
you know it's past half a million
already as we've looked into this data
so what did uc davis do during this
entire ordeal and uc davis does have
the distinction and not that we're
necessarily proud of it but the
distinction that we were the first place
in the united states to encounter
the first known communi first known
community acquired case of cobit 19.
so that was february 26th and what that
inspired us to do was we needed to move
much faster mainly because the virus was
literally at our doorstep
and you can see here the timeline going
from february 2020
out towards the future we really trace a
traced our
development of various cova tests
relative to what fda allowed us to do
you can see february 29th was our
so-called d-day where the fda
did relax regulations allowing
commercial and
regular clinical labs like ourselves to
actually
deploy and submit data for an emergency
use authorization for covet 19
tests and shortly thereafter
commercially available
covet tests based on the cdc assay was
also available but of course we're in
very short supply
in fact by march 19th we were one of the
few places in the state that had
the capacity to run testing and everyone
was really competing for the same
instruments the same rna extraction kits
the same pipette tips perhaps the same
pcr plates and so on
and that started a very long saga of
short supplies and so forth at our
institution we were also very lucky to
have had
already installed um a few months
earlier so december of 2019 a high
throughput pcr system so this is one of
the automated platforms
which when an assay became emergency use
authorized on it
we were able to deploy it um just nine
days later so on march 28th we deployed
the first high-throughput pcr system
in the region and our sister university
of california hospitals
which had similar platforms did the same
we continue to
add more testing just as many of you in
the audience who dealt with covid19
you were adding more tests more
capabilities expanding and really our
our doctrine starting in late february
was
first to deploy testing as soon as
possible followed by scaling
to meet the needs of our patients first
and then see
what else we can do thereafter and then
lastly but certainly not least
begin incorporating other pcr tests that
can help
augment testing in special populations
such as the emergency room
perhaps the community perhaps special
populations such as our transplant
patients needing to get cleared for a
kidney
you can see by april we brought in
serology testing we brought
backup instruments because we knew that
all of our eggs are now in one basket
with that one high-throughput system so
we got a second one
we also looked at uh pcr platforms as
noted with our third
component of our plan was to bring in
faster tests so in this case a platform
was
deployed by april 30th that was able to
get results back in about an hour and a
half and that continued
throughout the entire year and we'll go
into details of other platforms we used
at the university of california and
specifically uc health so these are five
hospitals under
the university of california so uc davis
being one of them but you have
university of california irvine los
angeles
san diego and san francisco and you can
see that we were
pretty much strategically located across
the state of california
and centered around population dense
dense areas such as los angeles san
francisco's and so forth
and davis of course helped into areas of
the central valley
and you can see all five health systems
rose up to the challenge and began
increasing our testing capacity to
support the
growing demand of the pandemic
as we deployed various tests we became
very much appreciative of
what this virus was and what we were
trying to target
to get results to our health healthcare
providers so that they can make
the best judgments sars cov2 is an
envelope positive sense single strand
rna virus
it's related to mers so middle eastern
respiratory syndrome
as well as severe acute respiratory
syndrome
sars virus as we used to cholestarus
2003 and now of course we call it sars
cov1
the mechanism for infection is binding
via the
spike protein so which are these
mushroom shaped proteins shown on the
left right there on that viral cartoon
cross section
and these bind to the ac2 receptor found
in various
organs and tissues that we have which
then facilitate the virus to invade
those cells and of course
take advantage of our host machinery to
replicate
detection is primarily and is accepted
to be
molecular diagnostics and molecular
course typically means
polymerase chain reaction or pcr this
being an rna virus we have to add two
words in front of pcr
and that's a reverse transcriptase or
reverse transcription pcr so we gotta
convert the rna to dna before we
perform the actual pcr steps themselves
there are other techniques are non-pcr
based these include isothermal methods
which i'll mention very briefly
but for the most part when we hear
molecular approaches the majority of
tests out there today remain
rt pcr so reverse transcription pcr for
covid in this case
at the end of the day pcr molecular
approaches really is
serves to amplify a small signal which
is the
strand or strands of rna of the virus
amplified made
many many times so that we can actually
measure it accurately and so forth
so when we talk about these molecular
tests we talk about targeting genes so
we use these genes as a circuit for
identifying the virus itself
so you can see here these are the common
tests we use at uc davis these are four
tests specifically
and you can see that each of these tests
do target different genes which work
quite well for us because it gives us
options
in the event that there are perhaps
mutations variants and perhaps
situations where
the viral load has gone down because
it's
recognized that the genes that these
viruses replicate
may not always be replicated in a
one-to-one fashion some genes may exist
more than others
these sub-genomic rna can help us
improve detection of the organisms at
certain stages of infection
we unfortunately don't have time to talk
about the science behind that but the
take home here is
not all tests are created the same the
genes do matter
and sometimes they don't compare well
just because for that reason in addition
to other pre-analytic factors that we
may have to factor in
we're very lucky here that these
platforms targeting these genes
avoid the regions that have become
identified
in variants so you can see that the uk
variant for example
there are mutations in the spike protein
therefore it means that this s gene in
this case could have changes
likewise the open reading frame or or h
region
may also have mutations that can affect
the performance of temposum tests
does that mean that these tests you have
a test that detects the s or orf8 region
it's a bad
test no main uh many tests that have
been employed today target more than one
gene
and oftentimes you're able to at least
pick one of the two or three genes
that are designed to be detected in
these
assay so you know it just makes you
have to keep your eye open as these
variants do emerge and so forth because
we are seeing these variants take over
very quickly in fact i think the recent
news reports say that the uk
variant is now the predominant strain in
the united states
here's a table uh illustrating um and
for educational purposes
only of five tests that we deployed at
uc davis and you can see that we kept
adding new tests
and you can see here that we have how
fast they are
how low they can detect in terms of the
rna how sensitive they are how specific
they are
the test capacity or their throughput i
do want to mention that sensitivity and
specificity are indicated on here
really more so to allow discussion
and understanding by all populations so
i do recognize that there is no gold
standard
for kova testing including molecular
diagnostics
so from the fda standpoint we should be
calling sensitivity
positive percent agreement and
specificity negative percent agreement
but i do know that outside the united
states that terminology may not be used
but you can appreciate from this table
that as we looked at the various tests
including the first test we deployed
they do have different flavors and
capabilities to detect
the organism you can see that as we
evolve we got more and more
sensitive tests and the limit of
detection or lod
as indicated here our best test right
now can detect as low as 1800
viral rna copies per ml these
values right here may differ from what's
reported by the manufacturer in their
product insert this is data from the
fda's
reference panel so this gives us means
to compare apples
and to apples hopefully but you can see
that some of these tests are slower
but they can turn out more results at
once so
our second row right there that high
throughput system can do 94 tests every
three hours
but we also have very fast tests you see
november 3rd we deployed a very rapid
20 minute pcr test that actually also
detects
uh flu a and flu b in addition to cyrus
cov2 but you're limited to testing one
sample at a time
uh this was highlighted by our pup press
release here we were one of the first
places in the country to deploy this
test and we had a we have a nice
multi-center paper out there
with a variety of collaborators that
show the real world performance of this
test
and the best part is it is indeed 20
minutes and it can be used by wave
users and we in fact deployed it in our
emergency department and select clinics
and we've expanded it further
since then allowing populations that
need rapid results where rapid decision
making is required
allowing folks to use this test very
easily
and to be able to use it and get results
on time and take action as needed
what's fascinating during this pandemic
is now we see the emergence of
home molecular testing and some are
prescription
based so needs a prescription others may
not we're heading in that direction
and i can say that from a laboratory
medicine
um a professional laboratory medicine
professional
i i definitely saw uh the the potential
for point-of-care infectious disease
testing using molecular techniques that
definitely was in the tea leaves
but i definitely did not see how fast we
got to the point where we now have a
home
molecular test this platform here i
believe it was the first to be approved
on november 18 2020 and in this case uh
it uses an isothermal molecular method
it is you know quote less accurate than
pcr but you know it is still very good
it's still a molecular test we're just
comparing you know this to the
the effective accepted standard being
pcr
um it is pricey about 50 for test but as
these technologies scale and grow you
can see these numbers change as they
move forward
uh it seems to have a agreement of about
94
with pcr so again um take that
for a bit of a grain of assault because
you know these results uh comparisons
they are against different methods so
there is still no gold standard but that
is a very promising
94 and this opening of home testing does
create new opportunities to
address this pandemic in particular how
do we
screen populations right so for those
that were in the
thick of things with covet 19 early on
really your your your colleagues at the
bedside
um your your patients um perhaps even
the community
everyone just wanted a way to test for
cobit but as the pandemic evolved
probably by the time we got to april
the question comes up should we be
testing everyone because we became more
appreciative of the fact that
these asymptomatic populations were
spreading the virus without
anyone knowing and the question came up
should we be testing everyone pcr should
we test them every day
every other day every week those
questions were very important
and the the question about testing
frequency is important because of the
fact that
if you just test someone every three
days or every week
you may miss that window when they have
high viral
load which would make them perhaps more
transmissible more infectious as it were
and you can see here that that may be
cost effective and resource effective
however you now gave folks three to four
days of walking around
interacting with the rest of society
while they
are at peak viral loads right and that
may not be as helpful especially when
we were at the height of the pandemic on
the flip side if you're going to test
everyone every day
once a day every day so that you catch
that moment when their viral load is
detectable
that sounds great it may not be great
from a nasal slob or nasal pharyngeal
spot
standpoint but more importantly it was
very it would be very expensive
supplies chain constrained and so forth
so it comes back to
what's on this website rapidtest.org and
it highlights work
and suggestions by dr michael mina that
identifies that
testing frequency and test availability
is perhaps more important than
sensitivity
in the context of trying to control this
pandemic and i know early papers even
suggested a sensitivity as
low as 70 percent could still make a
difference
and the uh the logic behind this is yes
if
seven out ten times you're going to be
able to
get you know get that right but of
course 3 out 10 times you're going to
have a false negative
but you're able to repeat testing the
next day where both you're rolling the
dice again
the metaphorical dice again but also at
the same time you're aligning the viral
load to creep up a little bit more in
the person so that you can pick them up
this may play a big role for those that
have been trained in lab medicine you
typically were taught that no test is
better than an inaccurate test and
whenever anyone
hears these stories of well 70
sensitivity is good enough you hear a
gasp
you should have no test is better than
an accurate test but the question now
now a year later from the pandemic i ask
what do we really define as an
inaccurate test today and for this
purpose
are we here to diagnose someone to know
if they need to be
treated if they need to be admitted yeah
we definitely need a good
test but we're just screening
populations to be able to pick up
infectious people to minimize clusters
of
virus perhaps a lower sensitivity may be
useful
but it requires everyone to be playing
the same game and therefore you see that
blue dot right there on the left
you can see a rapid test that detects
the virus at that point may be useful
you lose a little bit of sensitivity
but it's if it's available it's cheap
and so forth and hot as highlighted here
this model testing is only achievable
with rapid readily available
and cost effective testing this brings
us to
the other arm of testing so we have
molecular approaches initially
and now we discussed immunoassay
approaches and the early amino acids
really revolved around serology testing
which we won't spend
any time on this topic today because
that's not the point of this
presentation but just briefly obviously
serology testing is using immunoassays
to detect our antibody response
following exposure
to cyrus cov2 and perhaps one day
we may be able to also identify if you
are immune or not that's still up in the
air and we're still waiting on
the science to evolve and the course
guidelines to evolve with it
in the context of of diagnostic testing
immunoassays can be used to target viral
structures so going back to that cross
section of the virus
that we have right there on the left you
can see assays could perhaps target the
spike protein
and perhaps a target the actual nuclear
capsule proteins which is the most
common
the data we pulled back in september
there were quite a few tests out there
and the vast majority of them
were aimed at targeting people who were
symptomatic right
these are the people that perhaps have
the highest viral loads these are the
people that have the highest pre-test
probability to have
a true positive result it is recommended
a lot of these
assays that uh populations um that have
a negative result
should be considered presumptive it may
re require retesting with a molecular
method
and often the results that we see for
these tests on their information for use
so their product inserts
show a sensitivity of about 84 to 96
and hopefully better tests are to come
the tests that we see
often early on were point of care tests
so some required a reader
an instrument others did not uh most are
lateral based in fact this picture here
these are all lateral flow-based or
similar
flow blaze tests out there some even had
a smartphone app
give you a so-called pass that shows
your test and how long ago you tested
and they're very cheap to produce and
easy to ma and easier to manufacture
compared to molecular diagnostics even
if
compared to home molecular tests right
so if you use the analogy of a urine
pregnancy test that's available over the
counter
that's how easy it is to make these
tests so going back to
the model that dr michael minnow
suggested here we really have some
choices as we went through the pandemic
we could go down a pathway of high
frequency pcr
testing that's expensive resource
intensive
and oftentimes many facilities found out
that they're going to have to come up
with their own custom tests
to bypass common supply chains and so
forth some have even
used sequencing based technologies to
get the numbers up
but you pay a price you pay a price
oftentimes
um in terms of how long it takes for you
to get a result when you test and nest
so for example and i'll just propose
this to the audience today
that's great that you can do 100 100 000
tests per day
but how fast can you accumulate 100 000
samples to be able to run it
right it's not going to take 20 minutes
right so still will take a bit of time
and oftentimes that we've seen um best
case scenario most of these places are
turning out results within 24 hours
that's fantastic
but oftentimes we're talking a couple
days so 48 to 72 hours
and of course as you saw during the
height of the pandemic
various commercial labs actually even
have turnaround times that
were even on the order of a week and a
half which was
unfortunate so this goes off to the next
model of well
if we can't turn that out handle that
many results every day because it was
expensive we could test people every
three days
and that makes sense because you can
accumulate enough you have some time to
run it and get results back to people
but that's still there's windows of time
where people can still be infectious and
you may not know until it's too late so
if you tested on monday
and retested the person again on friday
and they were negative monday and
positive on friday
when did they became positive and how
many people were they exposed to between
monday and friday so those are the
challenges that we face
with these types of tests when anagen
testing came out
we were very happy from the perspective
that acknowledging that they may be less
sensitive than pcr
we were excited by the fact that we now
have another supply chain
another option and perhaps means to
to test dr minnow's hypothesis in this
case to test frequently with a cost
effective perhaps readily available test
unfortunately a lot of these tests were
not fully available in fact the
department of health and human services
actually sequestered a lot of these
tests so
early on these weren't available and
they were targeted towards
communities and some health systems and
also retirement homes and
nursing facilities of skilled nursing
facilities
so we also recognize as we tested
populations and perhaps
these weren't the best populations these
could have been low risk populations
uh they were prone to false positives so
even if these tests had a 99 or 98
specificity uh when the prevalence was
low your positive predictive value isn't
so great right so we can do the math
there
and and see why that is a problem uh but
we do see that later
point of care anagen test this is from
our colleagues at uc san francisco
they show here that these um and these
tests are were able to um
do reasonably well and when we actually
evaluated their sensitivity
relative to what's called a ct cutoff so
if you recall from pcr testing
real-time pcr reports ct values which
are cycle threshold values
and the bigger the ct value the um the
lower the viral load is right there
so if you're able to kind of put engine
testing and pcr testing on so-called
more even
ground to compare we may have to define
a ct cutoff so that
we would know when perhaps a person is
likely to be antigen
negative relative to pcr because they
are perhaps convalescing and there's
less viral load
where there's no more proteins that are
present the virus isn't producing as
much proteins
replicating as well and therefore that's
why the antigen is lower
if you look at data from the cochrane
report there's actually quite a recent
review here and this is from march 24th
they looked at uh quite a few uh studies
so in this case for symptomatic patients
being tested by antigen testing you see
from 37 uh
uh 37 evaluations consisting of 27
different studies
and summing about over 15 000 samples
you can see that
the the overall sensitivity of these
tests are about 72 percent
specificity is reasonably good at 99.5
percent
but the other thing i want to call your
attention to is asymptomatic testing
and this is where the focus has been now
because we are talking about reopening
schools
businesses reopening whole states whole
cities
and the asymptomatic population is where
we worry and
unfortunately you can see here that the
sensitivity is at about 58
uh specificity remains reasonably good
so at 98.9 percent but
sensitivity did suffer in this cohort
uh if you look at the types of tests
that were looked at you can again see
the
symptomatic versus asymptomatic patients
you can see the sensitivity and
specifics do vary by different platforms
too
uh and you can see in this case amongst
the asymptomatic population
one antigen test appears to have at best
a 69.2
sensitivity when compared against pcr
so what does all this data tell us uh
and where do we need to go from here
and this data tells us that we do need
better antigen tests the point of care
tests
have a role i'm not trying to discount
that that they may not perform well they
have a role we need to test in the right
populations
but we now are coming to an age of
laboratory-based antigen tests and
how does this change our our
understanding
and appreciation for deploying these
tests in contrast to point-of-care
antigen tests as i've
shown you which can only really do one
test at the time
laboratory-based antigen tests are are
going to be high throughput
they're going to have scalable reagent
supply they are going to perhaps be
lower cost due to economy
due to economies of scale why do i
believe that well
for those that operate in a clinical
laboratory specifically in clinical
chemistry
you know how many thyroid hormones you
run you know how many
vitamin ds you run you know how many
cardiac troponins you run and
manufacturers can scale
to that reagent level and so just for
context we could be looking at tens of
thousands of tests
per day they are definitely cheap in
some cases we could have
only a few dollars per test so you can
see here that there could be some
potential improvement in sensitivity
because we're using perhaps
lab laboratory based analyzer so that
may be of value compared to point of
care test but what's also valuable with
these laboratory-based tests is they
don't use proprietary media so
what i failed to mention earlier was
these point-of-care antigen tests
very convenient very fast but they often
use
a proprietary media that required you to
pretty much
add some reagents which pretty much make
them not feasible to be rerun by pcr
again in contrast some molecular
platforms may be able to use
a residual sample from laboratory-based
antigen tests and these are things that
are very exciting as we move to the next
phase of testing
during the pandemic so the pros and cons
uh here really for high throughput
lab-based antigen testing for cobin 19
you could be looking at 3 000 tests per
day on
instrument if you have the right
instrument the sense the claim
sensitivity specificity has been
reported to be about 97
sensitivity greater than 99 specificity
reagent supply seems to be stable
sufficient volumes
could these sufficient volumes of
capacity to make a noticeable dent
in testing deficiencies in hospitals
the sensitivity is acceptable for these
populations and could be used for lower
risk
patients the cons however a lot of these
tests require you to add some sort of
reagent a license buffer or stabilizing
buffer
sometimes it's within a very short
period of time so within 12 hours of
collections others we are seeing at 24
hours of collection
you can have staffing limitations who's
going to be the one that aliquots these
pipettes in these reagents to stabilize
the
samples right so you may have to think
about that if you lack automation or
automation that can do that
uh there is a shortage of serial pipette
tips at the time of putting together
this slide it's still not that great
and you should be using sterile tips and
um and this would affect if you don't
use sterile chips you can't reflex the
pcr right you could be introducing
contaminants
uh reagent stability that's going to be
ever evolving as manufacturers roll out
new tests you see that they will
have shorter stability and of course as
time evolves you'll hope that they will
have a longer stability time
so at uc davis health we are very lucky
to have access to
a previously uh laboratory-based energy
test which now has received emergency
use authorization
and in full disclosure we brought this
test and evaluated it
mainly because we were very concerned in
december and january that our pcr
supplies were dropping too quickly due
to that last surge
so this laboratory antigen test was
going to be
our backup plan uh fortunately or
unfortunately we never deployed it
so we were able to have some good data
to see how well it worked compared to
our pcr platform
but you can see here that we looked at
all of symptomatic and asymptomatic
patients that compared them all combined
too
but we also applied that ct value cutoff
and we looked at
comparing without a ct value cut off we
looked at comparing with a ct value of
33
we looked at comparing against a ct
value of 30 on pcr
and you can remember just higher ct
values mean
lower viral load and what's important to
appreciate here
is that is that on the bottom right hand
corner
we are ultimately um we are ultimately
uh having a 95
uh sensitivity and 90 um specificity in
this case
so ultimately uh this is reasonably good
and as this only occurs when you have a
ct
value of 30. so this is
an important point to appreciate you
look at ct value of 33. it's not too bad
either a sensitivity of 92.7
uh for symptomatic patients and
asymptomatic um
has 78 this isn't isn't too bad
and it actually uh allows us to evaluate
um
the uh the actual um process for
actual uh using in these populations to
screen for patient populations
so with that said we ultimately
appreciate here that these tests could
be employed if we
can come to terms with using ct cutoffs
as
a means to put pcr on the same
plane as antigen testing this leaves us
also the discussion that
can a person who's antigen negative a
pcr positive with a high ct
value be actually
infectious enough or perhaps less
infectious no one has an
answer to that question yet but you can
perhaps
feel that as a provocative hypothesis
because of the fact that if the virus
viral proteins aren't there
are the whole viruses there at all we
don't know that
and there are challenges in how we can
test for that with viral culture and so
forth because
there are limits to that technology as
well
regardless as we look at how cdc guides
us in this case they went with
a prevalence and pretest probability
based
algorithm so you can see here if you are
symptomatic and you are antigen positive
they're going to say that you are
infected with cov2
so they're not going to require you to
confirm that energy result however if
you're symptomatic and antigen negative
you may need to actually follow up with
some sort of nucleic acid amplification
test
next in the middle column you can see if
you're asymptomatic and have close
contact with covid19
chances are if you had someone that was
near you with cobit 19
you're more likely to um actually uh
catch it right so therefore if you're
antigen negative you're
you're likely to be truly negative if
you're you're positive then they would
recommend that you confirm
by naat lastly and on the right most
column you can see that asymptomatic
patients with no known exposure
obviously if your antigen positive let's
see if that's a false positive or not so
they're going to need you to reconfirm
if you're energy negative then it's
likely that you are not infected
with covet 19 or stars cov2
so in conclusion the kovid 19 pandemic
has created unique challenges globally
with laboratory minutes in playing a
central role diagnostic testing consists
of molecular and engine testing
engine testing is slowly emerging as a
potential low-cost
adjunct to molecular solutions early
sars cov2 engine tests exhibit
low sensitivity and specificity things
are improving
such as these newer laboratory based
tests that we are seeing especially as
we assess them
in more even grounds with looking at
their ct values when they're compared
against
pcr our best practices right now as far
as kobe 2 engine testing should rely on
pre-test probability as defined by cdc
guidelines
but the technology and the science
continues to evolve
and so forth so we'll have to wait and
see but we do see a valuable role of
energy testing you just have to use it
in the right
population so with that said i'll close
out and thank you everyone for your time
and i'm now happy to answer any
questions
and thank you so much dr tran for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's take a look it looks like we
already have a few questions
that have come in so dr tran
is pcr testing screening for dx
kobe 2 etc the only real option
given its recognition to the gold
standard
and i think that that's a great question
so i would probably
say there there's um a couple answers to
that it really depends on what you want
to do with that result right
so for instance if it's uh if we we
definitely need to act on a result
meaning that we're gonna give you a
therapeutic
you know a life-saving therapy we're
trying to figure out why you are super
sick and needing to be admitted
yeah molecular testing should be the
primary means to do that
if you are talking about um needing to
get tested to go
fly on a trip there's a lot of
discussion
with that so various organizations the
airline industry and so forth and
different countries have a lot of
opinions on this
right now they're saying it's gonna be
molecular testing of some kind i don't
believe as of yet
antigen testing is accepted uh for
um as a pre-test and return pre-return
uh screening uh tool for testing um
other perspectives however if you're
really just looking at
seeing how um your risk for having
covid19
based on what i showed you on those cdc
guidelines energy testing may work a
good example of this is
our use of antigen point of care testing
as part of migrant worker testing at uc
davis so
these are people that don't have the um
the financial means
the travel means or really the time to
come to a hospital to get tested with
our fancy molecular tests
however there's a lot of these people
out there and we're called diagnostic or
testing deserts as it were
and these are high-risk communities so
we decided to deploy
engine testing out there because there's
no real cost effective solution
for molecular point of care testing for
these populations so in this case we use
antigen for that and that does
play a role thank you so much now what
do you see
as a biggest challenge with antigen
testing for cov2
i think that the two challenges um are
first off
whatever we decide to do we have to go
all in we can't have
a situation where some people decide to
use antigen some don't
and and for any pandemic related
solutions
everyone has has to be rowing in the
same direction to use that analogy
otherwise it's going to be piecemeal and
unfortunately a lot of the early
pandemic
response was that and that's because of
sheer desperation right people were
looking for different types of tests
now the second issue and i feel this is
the bigger barrier
is really uh health care health sciences
we've all been pro including me
we were all programmed that molecular
testing is the way to go
and in some cases it's extremely hard to
break uh healthcare practitioners away
from what they've been trained
and i understand it because that you
know that the potential for a 10 to 15
false negative rate does scare people
uh however how like i said many times in
this presentation
it's who you're testing because if you
talk to a population where there's
hundreds of thousands of people in a
testing desert where
zero people or very few people have
access to testing
that eighty-five percent sensitivity or
even seventy percent sensitive
starts looking darn good uh because
that means that i'm catching a majority
of people that would have the disease to
prevent spread to
others so i think the challenges with
antigen testing is we are victims
of of having been ingrained in the the
pcr world the molecular world but also
at the same time
it it's going to be hard for people to
get away from the news stories
where early antigen tests were used
probably in the wrong populations
and causing false positive false
negative results and it has incurred
a perhaps less than ideal name and that
can be a barrier to adoption
at various facilities
thank you so much and we have one more
question from our audience
where do you see in lab high throughput
antigen testing
fitting in as we move toward forward in
the pandemic
i think as prevalence goes down that
will help a lot and i think as people
start realizing how much it costs right
now because you know early on some tests
were subsidized some tests were
augmented by various means
uh but when it's still um you know
double digits or plus
or three triple digits for a pcr test
uh people it starts adding up and
and i think as the prevalence goes down
we have a handle on the virus and the
majority of people are vaccinated
energy test starts looking real good
because of the fact that they are going
to be inherently
cheaper they are fast the data for it
looks good as long as using the right
population and
i think that's where it's going to be
let's put into context
hiv testing i know you know this is not
covid but
for context and perhaps i'm comparing
apples and oranges
because obviously hiv doesn't have a you
know a 30
asymptomatic population to worry about
it's not spread by
airborne droplets but at the same time
you look at the primary means to screen
for hiv is actually antibodies and
antigen
the molecular test is expensive we only
do it to effectively confirm and look at
viral load
so all these things are things to
consider as we shift to the post
pandemic world how do we be able to
cost effectively administer
testing for large populations as part of
routine care pcr is not going to go away
it will be used for confirmation and
perhaps still testing high-risk patients
but antigen i feel has a role especially
the lab-based platforms because they
have just so much capacity
and can do so cost effectively
dr tran thank you so much for your time
today would you like to provide me
closing remarks for our audience before
we go
sure well first i want to thank everyone
for taking the time to listen but also
you know
i think just stick with it you know i've
been here since uh you know
dealing with covid since february 26 and
probably a couple weeks even before that
of 2020
but the reality is you got to stay with
it because the science continues to
evolve and we have to remain flexible
and open-minded
in terms of what we do to continue to
fight the pandemic
absolutely and thank you again dr tran
for your presentation
and for your important research and i
also want to thank the lab roots and our
sponsor dia soren for underwriting
today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay healthy
and stay safe
take care everyone bye